[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
l'émission pour débattre discuter
échanger sur les sujets d'actualité vous
êtes habitué à retrouver mélanie poquet
pour cette émission mais elle attend un
heureux événement et j'en profite pour
lui c'est et plein de bonheur pour le
bébé qui arrive un peu avant l'été et
l'été il en sera question dans ce numéro
l'été résonne toujours avec les
festivals de musique enfin pas ces
dernières années du fait de la crise
sanitaire mais ces événements où les
artistes se succèdent et se produisent
en plein air sont de retour en 2022
alors le public sera-t-il au rendez-vous
comment les organisateurs
s'organise-t-il après deux années de
crise sanitaire les festivals retour à
la culture après deux années compliquées
pour en parler en plateau avec nous nous
avons eric boulo bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes le coordinateur de premières scènes
première scène c'est le tremplin des
jeunes talents musicaux en ile de france
organisée dans le cadre de rock en seine
et rock en seine c'est ça
[Musique]
key
alors vous l'avez eue le programme se
tiendra du 25 août au 30 août au domaine
national de saint cloud mais avant cela
il y aura à la sélection des grands où
des groupes de lycéens franciliens qui
participeront à rock en seine la finale
dans les yvelines a lieu le 18 juin avec
nous aussi pierre michel pinçon bonjour
bonjour vous êtes membre de
l'association met à ceux basés à voisins
bretons des vous organisés notamment le
festival la tourner mais les ouates et
la tournée des watts et bien c'est ça
là
[Musique]
j'adore
j'espère que les jeux
oui
l'année
[Musique]
la tour mais les watts et du 3 au 4 juin
2022 à l'espace culturel decauville à
voisins le bretonneux alors messieurs
comment vous sentez après deux années eh
bien sans ces événements culturels en
plein air durant l'été
motivé déjà parce que justement quand
l'activité ça ça fait du bien pour les
équipes mais je pense à faire du bien
aussi pour le festivalier ou bas il a
manqué complètement des événements
pendant toute cette période donc c'est
l'occasion de refaire un peu la fête sur
cette période enfin eric fehr ça va être
sa plus de fait peut-être pu rattraper
ces deux ans carrément on est vraiment
sur les starting blocks et on sent aussi
que le public est là et qu'il attend
avec impatience le festival et voilà on
a eu deux ans pour pour travailler sur
le festival et là c'est ça va être
l'occasion de présenter tout ce qu'on a
fait là depuis ces deux de ces deux
années mais parce que finalement vous
n'avez pas chômé pendant le pendant ces
deux années de crise sanitaire voilà on
a des projets notamment celui sur lequel
j interviens qui est première scène qui
est le donc le tremplin lycéens organisé
par rock en seine est en partenariat
avec la région ile-de-france
donc qui a été annulé la première année
parce qu'on est un tremplin qu'on
organise au printemps et voilà la
pandémie est tombé juste c'est à ce
moment là par contre on l'a maintenu la
deuxième
l'année dernière et on a réussi à tenir
toutes nos dates sauf celles sur le
festival puisque le festival été annulés
mais sur lequel on a pu innover et
monter un
une émission télé en fait première scène
tv où on a interviewé tous les ans fait
c'était un autre stress pour les pour
les jeunes qui participaient au tremplin
c'était pas le festival venir sur le
festival est joué mais c'était
participer à une émission de t d du côté
de mettre à la sauce commence son passé
comment vous avez vécu ces deux
dernières années ce que vous avez
préparé justement les prochains rendez
vous
alors oui et non parce qu'on était dans
les starting blocks qui a deux en 2020
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu beaucoup
d'incertitudes an pour la période même
pour l'annulation de l'édition 2020
comment tous les quinze jours ça a
évolué ça change et on savait pas trop
comment se positionner jusqu'à ce que le
couperet tombera en avril on a décidé de
le festival ne pouvait pas avoir lieu et
en 2021 c'est un petit peu différent à
cause des restrictions notamment la
buvette pour nous qu'une une grande
source de revenus les conditions en fait
étaient pas réunies pour qu'on puisse
accueillir les festivaliers dans des
conditions on va dire normal d'un
événement comme un festival comme la
tour mais les ouates festive où les gens
sont là pour partager se retrouver aussi
boire un coup n'y a pas que ça mais
c'est vraiment un esprit et l'on ne
retrouvait pas en fait l'esprit donc
c'est vrai qu'on s'est mis un peu dans
un stand by alors la programmation a été
reporté c'est la même programmation qui
était prévue en 2020 avec juste deux
changements d'artistes qui
malheureusement pouvait pas être
reconduit pour 2022 et
on a réussi à boucler une programmation
et à continuer à se remettre en chemin
pour pouvoir réaliser l'événement alors
avant de parler justement des
programmations comment vous avez
organisé les programmations vous avez
organisé un peu comme première scène en
2021 fin 2021 vous avez aussi organiser
un événement début 2022 au mois de mars
2000 un de ses thèmes et à le faire
exactement alors ça c'est un festival en
salles pour le coup qui est vraiment sur
l'esthétique que métal et musiques
extrêmes donc on l'a organisée à la
batterie de guyancourt et à celle de la
tour de voisins-le-bretonneux et ça a
plutôt bien marché même si les années
précédentes on était quand même complet
là on était un peu plus de la moitié de
la jauge est ok c'est une salle à 200
pour une reprise c'était pas si mal
voilà alors justement vous parlez de du
public de l'accueil du public ou est-ce
que ça en est au niveau des réservations
vous c'est début juin vous c'est fin
août il ya encore le temps mais où vous
en êtes là dans les réservations eric
wasser que nous ça se passe très bien
donc on est ravi il est vrai que les la
billetterie a été annoncé dès l'automne
ne s'y est pris très tôt
voilà les annonces des groupes se sont
fait rapidement tout au long de l'année
on a certains artistes également qu'ils
ont été reconduits comme wrage qui
reviennent ce qui était programmé les
dernières à qui est qui qui revient de
cette année comme red the machine par
exemple qui est vraiment une grosse gros
headliner
voilà donc là ça se passe vraiment bien
on attend entre 150000 à 200000 voire
même deux cent mille festivaliers cette
année à guichet fermé on espère et du
côté de 2 des mets ta sauce comment ça
se passe pour ce début juin bat plutôt
bien ça contrairement aux éditions
passées là on voit qu'il ya un
engouement on a un peu plus de ventes
sur la billetterie donc c'est plutôt
encourageant après là on arrive dans la
dernière ligne droite et on va mettre
tous nos mots nos moyens sur justement
la communication de faire en sorte que
les gens soient au courant alors nous on
rayonne essentiellement sur saint
quentin en yvelines le département
désigneront règle générale mais mine de
rien aussi un pont en ile de france mais
on reste quand même assez modeste c'est
un festival on peut accueillir 1500
personnes par jour
donc pour l'instant ça marche plutôt
bien mais il ya encore un peu de boulot
de notre côté pas sûr qu'on soit complet
mais on aimerait bien justement on
espère donc il faut qu'on fasse la
promotion de notre événement est
justement tout au long de l'émission
vous pourrez voir les sites internet de
chaque événement s'afficher si vous êtes
intéressés et acheter des billets pour
participer à ces événements parlons la
programmation justement comment vous
avez travaillé avec les artistes qui ont
eu aussi deux années quasi évident en
tout cas la culture s'est réinventée
avec la visio ou les concerts à distance
mais comment vous allez travailler avec
les artistes et ce qu'ils ont accepté
justement facilement de revenir à quel
coût aussi
moi c'est pas trop ma partie sur la
programmation juin intervient plus que
je disais sur son première scène
messieurs ce que je sais c'est qu'il y
avait beaucoup d'artistes justement en
tournée cette année justement qui avait
voilà donc il n'avait pas pu jouer
pendant deux années et du cookie
voilà qui étaient disponibles en tournée
donc j'ai beaucoup de propositions de
fait et on le voit d'ailleurs le
festival cette année c'est un festival
xxl puisqu'on passe de trois jours à
cinq jours donc c'est énorme il ya
vraiment un grand grand grand pas en
avant par rapport aux années précédentes
et on a plus de 80 artistes cette année
donc c'est voilà donc il ya énormément
de choix non qu'on sera du 25 au 28 août
il y aura quatre jours d'affilée puis un
off le vin le lundi 29 août pour ensuite
reprendre le mardi 30 août avec red the
game the machine également d'autres
groupes derrière donc repenser l xxl
pour 2022 un changement de dimension est
ce que justement vous du côté de mettre
la sauce le festival change de dimension
vous avez dit que finalement les
artistes qui étaient prévus pour 2020 et
ben sont programmés pour 2022 donc
finalement vous n'avez pas eu de
problèmes de programmation est ce que ça
change de dimension alors ouais ya un
changement de dimension c'est qu'en 2020
c'est la première fois qu'on devait
passer le festival sur deux jours donc
c'était déjà un petit challenge pour
nous donc sacré que les deux ans de
coupure on se dit bon maintien quand
même l'idée de passer l'événement a deux
jours pour nous c'est déjà une grande
première ça qui a pu comme je le disais
tout à l'heure de souci pour nous sur la
programmation après c'était plus de la
tente en fait de trouver les bonnes
dates de communiquer assez tôt au
tourneur aux producteurs des artistes
pour les dates qu'on vienne après ça que
dans notre réseau professionnel ça a été
finalement assez compréhensifs tout
n'était voilà a bien compris du nk la
situation était compliquée pour tout le
monde et l'idée c'était ba2
de trouver les meilleures façons de
fonctionner que ça se bile bien aussi
avec les autres organisateurs qui
assurent le territoire donc mais là
dessus on n'a pas eu trop trop de soucis
on va dire un mot quand même sur un
groupe qui va revenir peut-être
d'affiché cette année que vous aviez
déjà reçu en 2007 on a les images on y
était c'est hilight tribe ah oui grand
très content de pouvoir appuyer en plus
ils sont sur un nouvel album un nouveau
show donc là c'est vraiment
si je pu parler à adopter spectateurs
l'occasion de découvrir un nouveau
spectacle ça vaut vraiment le coup est
très content de pouvoir les accueillir
surtout avec ce nouveau spectacle juste
si on doit décrire leur musique c'est
assez particulier mais c'est
spectaculaire tout à fait c'est un peu
les pionniers de la natural trance
auxerre qui fond de musique techno en
fait avec des instruments acoustiques et
en effet c'est un premier en plus il
utilise bien d'instruments différents
qu'il est nos différentes régions du
monde donc ça que s'il ya une ouverture
culturelle et musicale assez
impressionnante un imprévu le dernier
jour c'est soit le 4 juin non ce serait
le temps qu'en argent exactement voilà
le 3 juin du côté de rock en seine la
tête d'affiche bon tout le monde le
connaît un c'est stromae oui il ya aussi
arctic monkeys voilà il ya nikkei et
puis radio gamme de machines également
donc voilà il ya kraftwerk également
donc voilà il ya pour vraiment un très
large choix c'est pour tous les goûts et
pour tous les goûts un mot sur justement
première scène c'est ce dont vous êtes
en charge pour le festival rock en seine
alors donc je le disais c'est un
tremplin un tremplin pour les groupes de
jeunes artistes des lycéens franciliens
limite d'âge interne ans et ce à la
limite d'âge était un 21 ans voilà il
faut que les allées les conditions
d'inscription il faut être donc le
groupe pour fait qu'ils se présentent
soit majoritairement lycéens donc certes
ils sont quatre à jouer dans le groupe
il faut qu'il nomme d'eux qu'ils soient
lycéens il faut que qui n'est pas plus
de 21 ans faux pas qui est le papa qui
joue dans le groupe par exemple c'était
déjà arrivé si j'avais des candidats qui
se présentaient comme ça donc
voilà il faut qu'il y ait deux
compositions également donc c'est c'est
un tremplin qui existe depuis 2010 sept
cas étaient donc créé avec donc en
partenariat avec la région ile-de-france
pour développer la pratique amateur
et on travaille donc en partenariat avec
une une trentaine de partenaires sur
toute l'île de france qui travaille à
l'année puisque on fait rock en seine
c'est aussi un festival qui s'inscrit
sur un territoire qui travaillent à
l'année aussi avec d'autres acteurs et
c'est ce qu'on fait sur sur ce tremplin
puisque qui mieux que des salles de
concerts qui ont des studios ou des
salles de concerts ou des associations
qui organisent des festivals des super
festival et qui font plein d'action à
l'année auprès des jeunes eh bien ce
sont eux qui sont les mieux placés aussi
pour repérer des jeunes groupes sur le
terrain et les inciter à s'inscrire
au niveau des inscriptions justement
voilà on est on est justement en train
de boucler pratiquement ont ici une
semaine ça vaudra on aura terme bouclé
toutes les inscriptions n'a pratiquement
une centaine de près presque une
centaine de groupes qui ont été repérés
voilà qui vont alors tous ne vont pas
pouvoir jouer sur sur les dates on a
multiplié on a des finales
départementales mais on a aussi des demi
finales dans les départements et avancer
demi finale on a essayé de ces
présélections on reçoit les dossiers et
on écoute les démos les
regarde les vidéos sur youtube ou sur
leurs instincts et sait et on
sélectionne donc les groupes qui sont
plus à même de participer non cherche
parce que ce soit des pros vraiment on
est vraiment sur la pratique amateur et
dans les yvelines deux dates un c'est le
12 juin lowe's le 11 juin à conflans
sainte honorine et le 19 ans
à rambouillet on cumulait à la mjc de
muszyna chapeau donc la première date
c'est à conflans sainte honorine à la
mjc les terrasses qui nous accueille
pour donc les présélections sur le 78
dans le cadre du festival bonne machine
qu'ils organisent chaque année
et là on aura six ou sept groupes qui
seront en présélection et de là on
sélectionnera quatre groupes qui
viendront jouer à l'usiné à chapeaux la
semaine suivante voilà le 19 juin et
s'il ya des groupes des génies siens qui
ont un groupe de musique qui sont
intéressés par ce concours n'hésitez pas
à vous inscrire sur le site qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran du côté de
mettre la sauce comment on perçoit
justement comment vous sentez
aujourd'hui la création musicale sur le
territoire où vous êtes le plus
localisées puisque vous êtes en contact
forcément avec des amateurs avec des
professionnels aussi comment vous sentez
est-ce que ça y est la reprise elle est
là aussi dans le monde culturel oui
alors ça cool association qui organise
le festival on a plusieurs activités
donc on a des yeux d'enregistrement et
de répétition pour les artistes du
territoire on organise également des
concerts en fait à l'année dans une
petite salle j'en parlais tout à l'heure
de 100 places debout et
on organise aussi des ateliers de
musique pour la pratique l'apprentissage
de la musique et donc on mène comme ça
des actions voilà au quotidien hors
festival qui est vraiment aussi un peu
le point d'orgue on va dire de la saison
donc sur la création musicale c'est
assez on sait qu'il ya des articles qui
sont des merdes et qu'on trouvait des
outils pour continuer leurs pratiques et
d'ailleurs ça que c'est un public on n'a
pas forcément retrouver à la reprise en
fait des activités donc nous on essaye
vraiment aussi d'aller chercher un
public qu'on n'avait pas avant donc on
se tourne de plus en plus en fait sur
les musiques électroniques donc sur ces
nouvelles pratiques ce soit dans le hip
hop ou vraiment la musique électronique
ce que nous on a pas mal de groupes en
fait aussi loisirs ou à des groupes de
rock de reprise et c'est donc là on
essaye de faire un travail finalement
qui a été engagée depuis pas mal
d'années mais qui s'est intensifiée
depuis ces deux dernières années depuis
la crise sanitaire sur comment toucher
un nouveau public en fait et des
nouvelles pratiques justement de la
musique donc il ya tout un chantier
actuellement à faire là dessus et on est
en plein dedans et nous
vraiment plein d'eau donc sur le
festival nous il ya six groupes qui sont
sélectionnés pour venir jouer entre
l'ile-de-france sur sur le festival ceci
qu'on peut lycéens et on voit depuis
depuis cinq ans en l'évolution est
effectivement cette année alors suite à
la pandémie alors on a beaucoup beaucoup
de groupes quoi de projets solos qui
s'inscrivent parce que pourquoi parce
qu'en deux ans les jeunes n'ont pas pu
aussi qu'il ya beaucoup qui n'ont pas pu
se retrouver pour répéter ensemble donc
il ya pas mal de projets qui sont
arrêtés quoi des groupes qui sont là
qu'on a pu jouer ensemble ils sont
arrêtés et d'autres qui sont mis qui ont
développé la pratique en studio chez eux
à la fois sur le hip hop ou les musiques
électroniques et ça on voit vraiment la
différence cette année on a on en a pas
mal comme comme ça donc vous là vous
parlez d'une tendance sociétale
justement une évolution de la société
suite à la crise sanitaire toujours en
chantier c'est ce que vous venez de dire
voir comment va se transformer
finalement
au fur et à mesure des au fil des années
voilà surtout quand on sait qu'une
association ala plus de vingt ans et que
comme on dire
sac sur les nouvelles pratiques bat
finalement on était un peu éloigné en
fait de ce public lorsqu'on a
l'impression après je sais pas si c'est
vrai ou si c'est faux quand c'est
institutionnalisé quelque part est donc
finalement il ya des jeunes qui vont pas
forcément vers notre structure alors
qu'on a les outils pour justement les
accompagnaient alors après c'est aussi
de s'intéresser à ce qui se passe et ça
je pense c'est important mais en tout
cas on essaye de faire ce travail de
fond c'est pas forcément toujours d'être
quoi leur objectif c'est pas forcément
de faire une scène tout de suite c'est
aussi souvent une il préfère faire du
clip voilà ça aussi avec l'évolution à
tous les réseaux sociaux les plateformes
et du coup on arrive à les aider à tirer
aussi sur sur première scène justement
pour l'heure pour qu'ils puissent faire
leurs premières scènes vraiment de
festival ils sont transformés comme les
camps voilà quand ils arrivent quand il
s'y met vraiment et c'est vraiment
chouette mois il ya eu vraiment une
image qui nous quitte mais restait de
l'année dernière ce qu'il ya deux ans on
n'a pas pu organiser le tremplin qui a
lieu donc en mai et en juin au printemps
et donc on a fait l'année dernière et en
fait toutes les dates qu'on a fait
l'année dernière à chaque fois qu'on
arrivait dans une salle on était les
premiers c'était les lycéens qui
inaugurait la salle après des mois
d'inactivité et c'était un bonheur de
voir tous les techniciens voire leur
plateau de scène vivre avec des jeunes
avec des lycéens
et c'est qui ce qui symbolise un peu de
vraiment le futur quoi de et c'était je
trouve que c'était une très belle image
d'avoir ça l'année dernière et de se
dire voilà on a tenu coûte que coûte le
on n'a pas lâché et est vraiment et ce
qui ouvre le lait des salles cette année
dans de toutes les salles partenaires
dans toute l'île de france eh bien
c'était des jeunes c'était des lycéens
est justement et les nouveaux talents on
pourra en peut-être découvrir de
nouveaux dans la prochaine édition de
première scène donc les sélections ont
lieu courant courant juin pour le
médiéval mai juin du coup pour le
festival rock en seine qui est du 25
août au 30 août au domaine national de
saint cloud on peut retrouver peut-être
là la programmation à nouveau je sais
pas si la régir le dire si on peut
retrouver la programmation le on va
finir l'émission en musique en fête
[Musique]
ranque ancien billetterie qui va
s'afficher en bas de l'écran et puis le
3 et le 4 juin 2022 vous retrouverez la
tournée les ouates de nouveaux musique
c'est parti
là
je
[Musique]
j'adore
j'espère que les jeux
m
mélangez tous nos habitants at elle
ajouté
eric goodell pierre michel planchon
merci d'être venu sur notre plateau
c'est la fin de ce sept huit sociétés
merci de l'avoir suivi une émission que
vous pouvez revoir en rythme et sur
notre site internet ou sur l'application
mobile à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
il